on ne pouvait mieux commencer l'année
1967 à bobino qu'avec le retour à paris
de gens grâce à l'ambiance y était déjà
dans les rues vis bien avant le lever du
rideau ou georges brassens entouré
sollicité et ne le quittant pas son ami
chabrol une georges jacques lemaire est
mû par une première sur une scène de
music hall et puis dans une autre loge
colette chevron une jeune chanteuse que
nous avons voulu vous faire découvrir
non pas d'un fauteuil d'orchestre mais
des coulisses les chevaux pour la
première fois que vous passez dans le
même programme que j'aimerais faire
non depuis que nous avons commencé à
travailler à 3 ça fait deux ans
maintenant chaque fois que george a fait
quelque chose un jour du tnt renée
patients semblent le trio en la faisant
de zapping l'élite noire le voisinage de
georges brassens effective ou bien vous
stimule ça m'effraie dans le sens par
exemple on a fait une tournée d'un mois
et demi j'ai essayé de faire des
chansons pendant ce temps là et à
écouter georges tous les soirs c'était
pratiquement impossible tellement ce qui
fait merveilleusement écrit
des complexes pour ce passage à bobino
je ne sais pas on va voir ça juste
monaco
j'attends c'est un pour moi c'est un
coup d'essai c'est à dire que je risque
je risque tous là ce soir mais bien sûr
je crois que je vais aller trouver genre
d'ailleurs pour vous demander de me
réconforter un peu
l'humeur et maryvonne aller
oui
valls il est je vaux et dans les
coulisses un auditeur attentif
georges brassens à part en quelque sorte
puisqu'il a été témoin à son mariage
moi qui suis partie vendue mario ne suis
pas tellement apprécié en public que je
vous propose
je crois que collègues que les choses
intéressantes elles cherchent évidemment
mascarons l'alpha team avec cabaret de
larry moss est excellente et les
chansons
alors un jour là décidé de ne plus
assurer des jeux sans l'agrément pour le
moment elle cherche à moi je crois
qu'avec l'aide de son mari vers la
finale
oui m'enfin moi je crois que françois
bayrou ce soit les premiers sauts les
plus difficiles encore peu parler
voilà et fond du tennessee s'était passé
je crois qu'il faudrait une émission
entière et les recherches par des mots
mais
non
je suis assez pour être sûr que jamais
chic et jeunes talents et des idées mais
on ne peut pas en même ne pas évolué
mais jamais deux fois le même nom ne
suis pas celui festif guerre tue pendant
plus de celui que je serai demain alors
forcément j'ai changé mais comme celles
ci ont dû se passer ton lentement
progressivement par degré on ne s'en
aperçoit pas aussi bien que les autres
ne salit g t au charbon qui s'est passé
le groupe et il est fier d'avoir été un
fan avoir allongé ici même par france
jamet ces jours là sauf moi de me trompe
constants le bon samaritain toi tu peut
se permettre